Oh what's going on YouTube and um I
don't know what say um for peaches
Wrangler ro for those of you who have
not seen this video this video is about
a 17 year old kid that gets his ass jump
by a gang of seven other kids and you
know me right the quiet type but y'all
know what it is
LD I said let's get it you need seven
dudes to beat up one person I don't give
a big-titty gorillas about the reason
for why you beat a human being like that
he could've [ __ ] on your lawn and no
human being deserves that kind of
treatment you know what the sad thing
about this [ __ ] is it was Asian on Asian
crime like I said before if you gonna
choose the life of being a thug a
degenerate or even a racist then you
might as well be the best one that you
can be what is it some kind of
interations of [ __ ] but you wake up in
the morning get a fight with your own
reflection I don't like your friends
it's a reflect it's the same face stuff
I'm gonna tell you something right now I
wish I was the one getting jump because
trust me homey you would have whupped my
ass at the moment but in the process I
went up you want to y'all that home
losing you a thug
[ __ ] I'm crazy to hell with swinging at
fist I wanna grab twist and pull the
Ripper
that's right little [ __ ] crazy always
beats thug and on top of this talk about
the most stereotypical way for you to
disguise yourself out of all the hood
disguise you could have used a stocking
cap over the face a do-rag saran wrap a
bill clinton mask you chose to dress up
like a walmart ninja here's another tip
if you gonna threaten some people maybe
you should step your game up son because
honestly those threats are I'm sorry you
know how I knew you were Asian it wasn't
because I read the description nope
it was because of that book ass English
you use when you were threatening him
yeah that's right that's right that's
what wait what Oh hold on I thought we
was gonna whup his ass nothing nothing
something in it I was a bit after this
ship went down I bet your boys had a
little talk with you huh hey dawg um I
wanted to ask you uh what was that whole
Kim thing about what oh no that wasn't
no I just you know my girl just broke up
me up I'm a little lonely I just this
part confused the hell out of me
why the hell did you suddenly turn into
Batman you seven guys are the sorriest
us I've ever seen in my life maybe I
should get you like a like a gangsta
start a kid or something nothing for
dummies
the Bible of gangbanging oh that's not
it dirty this is advice to all the thugs
in the world I know that MetroPCS has
camera phones now but it doesn't mean
that you should record every single
crime you commit if you're going to do
something stupid don't document it it's
like you robbing somebody than you
leaving evidence of the crime on purpose
I thought I got cheap let's get out of
here hey hold up you forgot to leave
your semen all over the place as
evidence oh that's right that's right
that's right
we aren't with you I'd only want you to
go to prison because that shit's way too
easy I was some weird [ __ ] to happen to
you I hope you get locked in a porta
potti for 14 days straight I pray that
you get lost in the middle Africa and
you get gang-raped by package' rafts I
hope you have mud butt and bubble guts
for the rest of your life when no toilet
paper
I will you two beside the jokes I'm
about to drop a truth bomb on y'all I
know there might be some of you they
might say well there's two sides of the
story it does not matter it does not
change the fact that what happened was
wrong
aside for the fighting opinion let's
take a look at the whole picture let's
say that this kid got beaten up because
it was retribution for something that he
had done previously in my neighborhood
people get beat up and smacked up all
the time the problem with this is y'all
actually believe that retribution in the
form of violence is justice and it is it
said now during this video I heard the
kids speak now well obviously he
couldn't speak English too well which
means that I'm assuming that like most
Asian American parents he came here and
so does parents for the same reason my
parents came in for his reason watch
this video doesn't really piss me off
but it breaks my heart I'm not gonna go
into this topic about Asian pride and
all that nonsense but as an Asian
American look back into your cultures
history and a little bit of the struggle
you didn't just embarrass yourself or
just tarnish your own image you did it
this service to your family your parents
and everything your parents fought to
keep you here and make sure that you had
a future you just put it to waste here's
a little something that you may or may
not know about me
I wasn't born here I came in this
country when I was 2 years old my mom
pop sacrificing everything that I could
live in this country and pursue
something that I believed in the
American dream of having having options
and choice and doing what I want to do
and making a living off of something
that I love and the parent to come home
and see your child beaten senseless to a
country that you brought them to that
you promised would improve their lives
it's something I can't even imagine I'm
not gonna be a hypocrite it's growing
about and make the best choices either
but here's a bit of advice that I could
give you kids out there think about this
the next time you try to get in a fight
with somebody when you try to hit beat
or even try to kill another human being
you don't just affect that one life you
affect everyone around them you think
that when you take someone's life you
take away one human being no you take
away maybe a father a mother a brother a
sister a cousin a family sense of
security it's not that simple
those of you out there they say that
even you even want these seven kids to
die you're just as wrong violence only
begets violence I'm gonna let you know
this right now world get your [ __ ]
[ __ ] together cuz this right here this
isn't it
[Music]
yeah here we have the indigenous Asian
people of the mountains oh I think they
spotted us as you can see the Asian one
the female killed a leopard and dragged
it over her neck for some time oh she
spotted us back down back away back away